vamos ahora con nuestro invitado del día
Rusia completó el retiro de sus tropas
de gersona de la ciudad más importante
que ha capturado el kremlin desde el
inicio de la guerra en Ucrania el pasado
24 de febrero entre tanto Ucrania ya
ocupa la urbe y se conoció que el puente
antonivski único punto de paso hacia la
orilla Oriental del río nieper colapso
estos últimos acontecimientos o podrían
marcar un cambio de rumbo en la guerra
por la ubicación estratégica de gerson
que además fue anexada ilegalmente en
septiembre vamos a ampliar esta
información y conectamos para ello con
Antonio barrios Oviedo él es analista
especialista en conflictos
internacionales y en origen y ampliación
de la botana bienvenido Y a lo largo de
esta entrevista señor barrios usted nos
explicará con la ayuda de algunos mapas
que usted mismo entregó a Franz 24 las
implicaciones de los desarrollos en
gerson Comencemos con las tropas rusas
aseguran haber completado su retiro
hacia la orilla derecha del río nieper
según Ucrania el puente antonivski que
conectaba la urbe colapsó Cómo deja esto
a rusos y ucranianos en el conflicto y
que otros de puntos de cruce tienen para
atravesar el nieper
Buenos días y gracias por la invitación
sí sin duda tanto tropas ucranianas como
las tropas rusas que dan en un punto
muerto porque el colapso de ese puente
impediría que tanto ucranianos como
rusos puedan pasar para continuar la
conquista en esta contraofensiva
ucraniana el hecho de haber logrado de
alguna manera que las tropas de Rusia se
devuelvan a la margen Oriental del río
niepero o lo que se conoce también como
el margen derecho del río nieper Pues
también es un muro de agua que le impide
a las tropas de Ucrania poder continuar
en la reconquista de gerson Y eso le
permite por otro lado a las tropas de
Rusia Pues de alguna manera poder
reposicionar a sus fuerzas militares
para también de alguna manera poder
seguir dominando lo que le queda al
territorio de jerson en la margen
derecha del río níspero Así que hay un
punto muerto en ambos lados del río y
eso hace que de alguna manera pues los
ucranianos al carecer de equipo militar
aéreo como helicópteros o aviones de
combate no pueda continuar su
contraofensiva en la margen derecha del
río nieper para poder seguir
conquistando el territorio y los rusos a
pesar de que también tienen una
superioridad militar aérea tampoco
pueden de alguna manera pasar al otro
lado porque las baterías antiaéreas del
ejército ucraniano Pues sería podrían
aceptarle a Rusia un duro golpe muy bien
en esa zona existe un canal en el que
lleva agua desde el río niéper hasta la
Península de crimea anexada por Rusia en
2014 Qué implicaciones tendría para la
península de Ucrania cortar o dañar ese
canal como tomaría Rusia un ataque
semejante
Bueno hay una situación ahí interesante
porque el 80%
del agua que requiere la Península de
crimea y los habitantes más de la
actividad económica que la Península de
crimea tiene pues es un 80% es decir
depende de los afluentes y de los
canales que a lo largo de los años se
han construido para desviar una parte
del río nieper y poder llevar agua a la
Península de crimea del río niepe tiene
aproximadamente 350 kilómetros de
distancia que atraviesan el territorio
ucraniano y del desvío este que se hizo
a partir de 1956 con una de las represas
más importantes que permite llevar agua
a la Península de crimea Pues eso hace
posible de que esta península pueda
recibir agua si la guerra de alguna
manera se traslada y los ucranianos de
alguna manera logran también poder
continuar en la contra ofensiva esto
podría llevar a que las fuerzas de
las fuerzas de selenski de alguna manera
lleguen a controlar
este canal recordemos que cuando Rusia
ocupó crimea
el gobierno de Ucrania lo que hizo fue
de alguna manera cerrar la llave y la
Península de crimea se quedó sin agua
pese a una serie de negociaciones es su
imposibilitó este esa situación así que
con la ocupación de la Península de
crimea de alguna manera también músculo
logró el control de ese afluente muy
importante y esto ha hecho que de alguna
manera hasta el momento crimea siga
recibiendo agua si la guerra continúa en
otro contexto distinto al que ha venido
ocurriendo y Ucrania logra el control de
gerson eso podría eventualmente traerle
problemas muy serios no solamente a
Putin sino a la gente que necesita ese
80% de agua para que crimea continuó con
su actividad económica hay un detalle
también muy importante que me parece que
hay que mencionar son 50.000 hectáreas
de riego que necesita crimea para poder
desarrollar su actividad económica y ese
80% del agua que necesitan proviene del
los distintos canales que a lo largo de
los años se han construido con este
canal del Norte que se denomina también
el afluente desviado del este el río
nepes señor barrios otra de las grandes
preocupaciones es La Represa de novaka
en el norte de tantos rusos como
ucranianos se han acusado mutuamente de
querer volarla y le pregunto En ese
mismo sentido Qué implicaciones tendría
para el sur de Ucrania y para la
continuidad desde la guerra la eventual
de destrucción de esa Represa bueno
selencio ha estado diciendo como parte
de su discurso de que Putin tiene
pensado pues volar o destruir La Represa
lo cual implicaría una gigantesca
inundación el río uniper antes de
desembocar en el mar Negro está
compuesto más por embalses hay
aproximadamente 100 kilómetros de
embalses que permiten precisamente pues
alimentar no solamente las plantas el
enfriamiento de las plantas nucleares
sino también alimentar a otros pueblos
muy importantes en ambos lados del río
ni igual que como lo dije anteriormente
Pues el canal especial que se hizo para
irrigar lo que es toda la Península de
crimea pero cuando se habla de que se va
a dar una voladura es algo que
definitivamente no le conviene a nadie
mucho menos a Putin porque volar La
Represa implicaría no solamente una
gigantesca inundación sino que
prácticamente pues la Península de
crimea se quedaría sin el agua que
requiere Así que desde el punto de vista
estratégico por lo menos de momento a
pesar de que excelencia ha estado
manifestando que eso es uno de los
planes militares de Putin Putin lo ha
desmentido reiterado su oportunidades y
desafortunadamente en la guerra Pues en
la guerra se puede decir de todo y
cualquier cosa puede ser tan creíble
como tan falsa en este contexto de
guerra que Ucrania ha estado viviendo
bien y finalmente vamos a otro de los
eventos que genera un giro en el
conflicto en los meses recientes y fue
la voladura del puente de kerrch además
es de un golpe simbólico para los
ucranianos esto supone un golpe al
suministro militar del frente sur de las
tropas rusas en Ucrania qué otras
implicaciones tuvo este evento en el
mediano y en el largo plazo o cuáles
tendrá bueno esta joya arquitectónica de
Putin Es evidente que le permitió
enlazar por primera vez este la
Península de crimeada con el territorio
continental de la federación de Rusia y
el haber volado este puente implica pues
le significó en realidad un problema muy
serio Porque no solamente era por una
cuestión logística militar que le
permitía a Rusia poder alimentar a las
tropas a las tropas que están
acantonadas en la Península de crimea
que sirven incluso Para apoyar a las
fuerzas de Rusia en este corredor
territorial que le permite también
conectar con dones y lugans esto también
afectó el comercio que es muy importante
entre la Península de crimea y el
territorio continental de la federación
de Rusia Así que Putin lo había
manifestado anteriormente Cuando ocurrió
este evento y eso afecta el comercio
afecta la logística militar afecta
también la economía de Rusia ante esta
ante este freno que hay en esta di
económica y ahí ya vimos lo que ha
pasado en los días posteriores a la
voladura del puente lo que significó la
contraofensiva de Rusia atacando a
distintas ciudades y sobre todo a kiev
Es parte digamos de lo que de alguna
manera el presidente Putin estaba
esperando como para justificar otra
serie de ataques distintos a la forma en
como se ha venido dando el curso de la
guerra en esta conquista territorial por
parte de Rusia en Ucrania claro y además
hay que recordar que se acerca del
Invierno Ucrania y esto genera toda una
serie de nuevas preocupaciones para el
gobierno desde kief y tal vez de
oportunidades para Rusia Así que veremos
Cómo se desarrolla el curso de la guerra
en ese sentido y nos queda perfectamente
claro entonces que gerson es un punto
geopolíticamente estratégico para la
guerra y que Quien tenga ejerzo uno Pues
tendrá nuevas posibilidades en los
combates Antonio barrios Oviedo analista
especialista en conflictos
internacionales y en origen y ampliación
de la otanna gracias a usted por su
análisis que además no se puso muy
gráfico en pantalla con mucho gusto para
servir